muy bien momento de hablar de economía
aquí en directo américa en france 24
está conmigo en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge buenas noches lo mencionamos en el
bloque de noticias este triunfo de los
demócratas en cuanto a esa legislación
pero eso requiere un desembolso grande
de dinero por parte del gobierno
definitivamente bueno hablamos de la
promulgación de esta ley de parte de joe
biden el presidente de eeuu que esté
sobre este proyecto de ley que atenderá
el clima y la atención médica la ley es
histórica por tener una inversión
federal nunca antes registrada sobre
todo para la lucha contra el cambio
climático se trata de una inversión por
430 mil millones de dólares que según el
mandatario le permitirán alcanzar sus
objetivos climáticos crear oportunidades
de energía limpia y luchar contra la
injusticia ambiental la ley que fue
aprobada por la cámara de
representantes- el viernes pasado
también planea ayudar a unos 13 millones
de estadounidenses a pagar el seguro de
atención médica prolongando los
subsidios proporcionados durante la
pandemia de coronavirus y permitiendo
que medicare este programa de seguridad
social negocios precios de medicamentos
más bajos para los ancianos con las
farmacéuticas la ley además garantizará
que las corporaciones y las personas más
ricas paguen los impuestos que deben con
la firma del documento de la casa blanca
el presidente estadounidense celebró
este triunfo para los demócratas
escuchemos
este proyecto de ley es el mayor paso
adelante en materia climática jamás
visto y nos permitirá dar pasos
adicionales con valentía hacia todos mis
objetivos climáticos y los que
establecimos cuando nos presentamos
incluye crear oportunidades de energía
limpia en las comunidades de primera
línea y cercanas que han sido sofocadas
sofocadas por el legado de la
contaminación y luchando contra la
injusticia ambiental que ha estado
ocurriendo durante tanto tiempo
mientras tanto en argentina anunciaron
un nuevo esquema de tarifas y también
nuevos subsidios para la energía la
noticia la dio a conocer la secretaria
de energía de ese país que dijo que se
eliminarán los subsidios en las facturas
de los servicios de gas a electricidad
de agua por medio de un plan escalonado
y según los niveles de ingresos y
consumo de los argentinos en materia de
energía electricidad y gas el gobierno
espera un ahorro fiscal de 350 millones
de dólares para este 2022 y de 14
millones de dólares quitando el subsidio
sobre la factura del agua con esta
medida el gobierno argentino aseguró que
se aliviará la carga fiscal del estado y
espera que el ahorro tenga un impacto
positivo de entre el 0,4 por ciento del
0,5 por ciento del producto interno
bruto para el próximo año recordemos que
argentina ya había acordado con el fondo
monetariointernacional realizar este
tipo de recortes en los subsidios
estatales a la energía y probablemente
tendrá reacciones en las calles con
algunos sindicatos quejándose por
supuesto como lo hemos visto con
decisiones que ha tomado recientemente
el gobierno argentino le haremos un
monitoreo a esto a ver si sucede jorge
hablemos ahora de la colombiana que siga
creciendo tal parece que a buen paso
pero no a los niveles de hace un año
bueno es que con cifras que superaron
las expectativas del mercado y del banco
central colombiano la economía del país
creció un 12,6 por ciento en el segundo
trimestre de este año empujado por la
recuperación de muchos empleos y la
reactivación de la industria sin embargo
esta cifra aún es menor si la comparamos
con el mismo período del año anterior
cuando se ubicaba en 18 3% pero hay que
recordar que en ese momento la economía
vivía el efecto rebote tras la pandemia
como muchas economías de américa latina
y del mundo la agencia estadística dane
aseguró que los sectores que ayudaron a
este avance económico fueron el de
comercio la industria manufacturera la
educación y la salud el presidente iván
duque que recién entregó la
administración del país el pasado 7 de
agosto aseguró que le dejó una economía
vibrante en vibrante reactivación pero
la nueva cartera económica del
presidente gustavo petro asegura que el
país quedó más bien con un profundo
vacío fiscales y pasemos ahora a hablar
de alemania en donde hay opiniones
completamente divididas en torno al uso
de la energía nuclear como una opción
para poder suplir la demanda
suministrada por bueno y todo debido a
este panorama de escasez energético en
alemania el canciller o las soes todavía
no tomará una decisión definitiva sobre
si continuar o no con los reactores
nucleares con los que el país cuenta
ahora el gobierno alemán espera un
segundo test de estrés sobre la
seguridad del suministro energético en
alemania para analizar si está
garantizado bajo los niveles más
estrictos con tres plantas nucleares que
representan el 6 por ciento de la
energía de alemania y con el 31 de
diciembre de este año como fecha límite
para que sean cerradas el país ha
utilizado el gas natural para producir
alrededor del 10 por ciento de la
electricidad porque muchas gracias por
esta actualización de las noticias
relacionadas con la economía punto final
a este bloque informativo en directo
américa a continuación el debate